The Lord of the Rings trilogy is littered
with epic sacrifices, gruesome deaths,
and both happy and sad endings. From
mighty warriors to slimy bad guys,
here are the last words of these fallen
Lord of the Rings heroes and villains.
Before we can discuss final
words, it's important to know
which final words we're talking about.
After all, in addition to author J.R.R.
Tolkien's original books, there's the animated
Lord of the Rings films created in the late
'70s and early '80s, and of course,
Peter Jackson's live-action trilogy.
In this video, we'll go with a combination
of the live-action adaptations and the
original books. However, some of the fallen
characters still don't have concrete "last
words" in either version. When this happens,
we'll give a brief rundown of their final moments.
After all, actions speak louder than words.
While not a primary character in The Lord
of the Rings, Isildur shows up early in The
Fellowship of the Ring film and is referenced
throughout the narrative. The ancient warrior
who cut the One Ring from Sauron's hand, Isildur
dies when he's ambushed by orcs, while trying to
escape across the Great River. In the film,
his last word comes long before his death,
when he rejects Elrond's plea for him to
throw the Ring into the fires of Mount Doom.
"Destroy it!"
"No."
However, in Tolkien's book Unfinished Tales,
Isildur's final line is a bit juicier.
Knowing he's about to be killed,
Isildur's son, Elendur tells his
father to bring the One Ring to the elves
before it's recaptured. His father replies,
"I knew that I must do so; but I feared the pain.
Nor could I go without your leave. Forgive me,
and my pride that has brought you to this doom."
Isildur's father, Elendil, is the first king of
the realms of Gondor and Arnor at the end of the
Second Age. During the same time, Gil-galad is an
elven leader who rules over the bulk of the elves
that remain in Middle-earth. Eventually, Sauron
picks a fight with them, and the two leaders form
the Last Alliance, a massive coalition that
gathers together to attack Sauron in Mordor.
The Last Alliance is ultimately victorious but
at the expense of both of these high kings.
They are killed in combat with Sauron
just before Isildur cuts the One Ring
from the villain's hand using
his father's broken sword.
While neither character is officially given final
words, they appear in both the books and films.
Their brave actions set the stage for Sauron's
first defeat at the end of the Second Age.
Everyone is fascinated by Sméagol, the hobbit-like
creature eventually known as Gollum. He steals
the One Ring from a friend on his birthday,
and in the process, murders his companion.
That friend is Déagol, another hobbit-like
creature. Five centuries before the Lord
of the Rings story begins, Déagol finds the
One Ring while out fishing with his friend.
When Sméagol sees the Ring, he demands that
Déagol give it to him since it's his birthday.
In the opening scene of Return of the King, the
poor fellow's response winds up being his last.
"Give us that here, my love."
"Why?"
In the book, Déagol says a
little more, telling Sméagol,
"I don't care. I have given you a present already,
more than I could afford. I found
this, and I'm going to keep it."
Sadly, poor Déagol doesn't realize
the tragic irony in his statement,
and winds up paying a much greater price.
Although Gandalf doesn't technically die, he
certainly gives everyone the impression that he
does, so his seemingly final words are still worth
noting. While staring down the Balrog he shouts,
"You shall not pass!"
Unfortunately, although Gandalf
successfully defeats the Balrog,
the fiery monster winds up
taking the wizard down with him.
As Gandalf realizes he's about to
fall, he cries out to his friends,
"Fly, you fools!"
Identical in both book and movie, the words
communicate a sense of care and frustration
which pushes the rest of the Fellowship members
into action. While he does return later in the
story, Gandalf's sacrifice is still a powerful
moment that's earned a spot on this list.
Also known as Durin's Bane, the fiery
Balrog demon seems indestructibly powerful
in The Fellowship of the Ring, but the
book reveals he's actually a refugee
fleeing from the catastrophic War of Wrath. In
that war, Sauron's original master, Morgoth,
is defeated, and his surviving servants scatter
across the continent, looking for places to hide.
The Balrog relocates deep beneath the dwarf
kingdom of Khazad-dûm for nearly 2,000 years.
Eventually, he's disturbed by the dwarves,
at which point he drives them away, and the
area becomes known as Moria or the "Black Pit."
When the Balrog attacks the Fellowship, Gandalf
confronts the demon on the Bridge of Khazad-dûm,
and sends them both tumbling into the abyss below.
As they fall, they begin an intense duel that
progresses from deep underground all the way up
to the top of the mountains above. There, with
clouds, fire, and lightning surrounding them,
the Balrog is finally killed by Gandalf. The
Balrog doesn't get any last words, but its death
clears the way for the dwarves to eventually
return to their ancient home of Khazad-dûm.
While most of the main characters in Peter
Jackson's films are from Tolkien's original text,
the uruk-hai captain Lurtz was
entirely Jackson's creation.
Lurtz leads Saruman's forces in pursuit of the
Fellowship, and provides an effective foe for
the main characters to defeat in the otherwise
villain-less finale of The Fellowship of the Ring.
After shooting Boromir full of arrows, the orc
captain takes on Aragorn in a one-on-one duel.
After a harrowing showdown, the Ranger wins out,
and Lurtz meets his demise with his
arm and head removed from his body.
Lurtz doesn't have many lines in the
film, and doesn't say anything at all
as he quietly duels multiple members of the
Fellowship during the film's ending battle.
However, shortly before his last breath, the
uruk-hai can be heard shouting to his men,
"Find the halflings. Find the halflings!"
Created with only one purpose, Lurtz's
final words are focused on his mission,
just like his whole life.
Heir to the steward of Gondor, Boromir joins the
Fellowship of the Ring only to succumb to the lure
of the Ring. But after attempting to steal it
from Frodo, Boromir repents and sacrifices his
life defending Merry and Pippin. Moments before
he takes his final breath, Boromir confesses
to Aragorn that he tried to take the Ring,
and that Merry and Pippin have been kidnapped.
He also urges Aragorn to go to help his
people, before uttering his final words.
"I would have followed you,
my brother.... My captain,
my king."
The revelation that Boromir finally
accepted Aragorn as his king
is the perfect way to resolve his previous
scorn for the Ranger at the Council of Elrond.
In the books, Boromir's final line reads,
"Farewell, Aragorn! Go to Minas Tirith
and save my people! I have failed."
Aragorn responds that Boromir
has not failed, but conquered,
prompting a smile from Boromir
before he breathes his last.
In Tolkien's books, the elf Haldir helps the
Fellowship out as they travel through Lothlorien.
But after the travelers depart down the
Great River, we don't ever meet him again.
In the movies, though, Peter Jackson brought back
the Lothlorien guide for the climactic battle of
The Two Towers. As the men of Rohan prepare
to fend off Saruman's hordes at Helm's Deep,
Haldir unexpectedly shows up with
a bunch of high-quality archers.
Unfortunately, in the ensuing battle,
Haldir meets an untimely death.
Just before Haldir's death, he shouts something
in his native tongue to his retreating men.
However, since we aren't sure of the translation,
we'll instead highlight the last thing he says
after arriving with his troops. Facing King
Théoden, he says he brings word from Elrond,
saying that they wish to honor the
old alliance between men and elves.
"We are proud to fight alongside men once more."
Originally sent to resist Sauron, Saruman the
White Wizard eventually becomes corrupted and
vies for power himself. This leads to
his overthrow in The Two Towers and his
eventual death at the hands of Gríma
Wormtongue in The Return of the King.
In the extended film version, Saruman's death
comes as he stands on top of the Tower of Orthanc
in the midst of the drowned ring of Isengard.
As he argues with Gandalf and his allies,
Wormtongue attacks him from behind, sending
him careening off the edge of the tower.
Just before he's killed, Saruman
can be heard saying his last words,
"You withdraw your guard, and I will
tell you where your doom will be decided.
I will not be held prisoner here."
In the books, Saruman survives until the end of
The Return of the King. By then, he's going by
the name "Sharkey", whom Frodo and his friends
discover has orchestrated the destruction of the
Shire. Defeated at last by the hobbits, Saruman
orders a broken Wormtongue to follow him, saying,
"You do what Sharkey says, always, don't
you, Worm? Well, now he says, follow!"
At that, the Wormtongue of the books finally
turns on his master and slits his throat.
We first meet Gríma Wormtongue
secretly betraying his king, Théoden.
After his duplicity is discovered, he openly
allies himself with the powerful Saruman, fleeing
to the White Wizard's domain at Isengard. There,
he serves his new master faithfully yet miserably.
In the films, he meets his ending early in the
extended version of The Return of the King. After
stabbing Saruman in a fit of rage, Wormtongue
is felled by an arrow fired by Legolas. His last
word, uttered moments before, is in defiance
of Saruman's dismal prediction of his future.
"Free? He will never be free."
"No."
In the book The Return of the King, a
fed-up Gríma backstabs Saruman again,
this time in the Shire after his
master is defeated by the hobbits.
Just before he slits Saruman's
throat and is shot by arrows,
Wormtongue is accused by his master of murdering
Frodo's cousin, to which he violently hisses,
"You told me to; you made me do it."
Théoden is already quite old when Gandalf frees
him from the spells of his counselor, Gríma
Wormtongue. After regaining control of himself,
the king of Rohan leads his armies to Helm's Deep,
where they win an epic victory by the skin of
their teeth. They then head to Minas Tirith,
where the aged ruler dies in a glorious charge
that kicks off the Battle of the Pelennor Fields.
It's none other than the Witch-king himself
who kills Théoden in battle. In the movies,
his airborne beast lands on the king,
whipping him around and sending both
Théoden and his horse flying to their deaths.
In the books, it's clarified that the Witch-king
actually kills Théoden's horse, who then
falls on the king, crushing him to death.
After Éowyn and Merry defeat the Witch-king
together, we get two different sets of
Théoden's final words. In the film The
Return of the King, Théoden says to Éowyn,
"I go to my fathers, in whose mighty
company I shall not now feel ashamed."
He then whispers her name one last time before
he dies. In the book, Théoden doesn't realize
that Éowyn is nearby. His final words are
spoken to her brother, Éomer, when he says,
"Hail, king of the Mark! Ride now
to victory! Bid Éowyn farewell!"
Both the book and the film give Théoden satisfying
last words, worthy of the noble king he was.
The millenia-old Witch-king is a recurring
villain throughout the Lord of the Rings trilogy.
He leads the nine Ringwraiths on
their deadly hunt for the Ring,
stabs Frodo at Weathertop, and leads the
massive army that attacks Minas Tirith.
After wreaking havoc on Middle Earth
for thousands of years, the Witch-king
finally meets his end during the Battle of the
Pelennor Fields. Overconfident from millennia
of successes and a prophecy that no living
man can kill him, he recklessly gets involved
in the fighting. After mortally wounding King
Théoden, he is confronted by Éowyn and Merry,
who work together to finish him off. In the
movie, his ironic last words to Éowyn are,
"No man can kill me. Die now."
In the books, his final
words are a little different,
but still set up Éowyn's iconic response,
before she strikes the killing blow.
"I am no man."
Although he's barely mentioned in the books,
Gothmog is second-in-command
during the siege of Minas Tirith.
However, in the film version of The Return of the
King, Gothmog gets a much larger role as a leader
high on his own authority who is convinced
that the age of the orc is about to begin.
His involvement in the films makes him a big
enough character to deserve a spot on this list.
In The Return of the King, we see
him ordering his soldiers around,
dodging boulders, and commanding his men
to brace for the charge of the Rohirrim.
Later in the battle, Gothmog can be
seen crawling towards the wounded Éowyn.
With his weapon lifted to kill, Aragorn and Gimli
arrive in the nick of time and finish him off.
In order to catch his last words,
you need to back up to just before
the Riders of Rohan come crashing into his army.
Prepping his troops for the incoming tidal
wave, his last words are the doomed command,
"Fire at will!"
As the steward of Gondor, Denethor is in charge
of leading Gondor in the absence of the true king.
Eventually, he breaks down under the
pressure of the ongoing attack from Mordor,
and tries to burn himself
and his son, Faramir alive.
In the movies, as Gandalf and Pippin
arrive to stop him from murdering his son,
Denethor's desperate near-final words are,
"You will not take my son from me!"
After Gandalf knocks him back onto the
blazing pyre, Denethor gazes on his son and
quietly utters his name as his last word, before
running from the room and falling to his death.
"Faramir."
In the books, Denethor's last lines are
directed at Gandalf before he lights the pyre,
and then to his servants, saying,
"But in this at least thou shalt not defy my will:
to rule my own end. [...] Come hither!
Come, if you are not all recreant!"
After this, he sets the pyre on fire
and purposefully lies down to die.
As he lies there, he gives one great
cry and then perishes amidst the flames.
Although he doesn't appear in the theatrical
version of The Return of the King,
the Mouth of Sauron makes a memorable
appearance in the extended edition of the film.
A powerful official in the Dark Lord's
bureaucracy, he comes out to haggle with
the captains of the West when they arrive at the
gates of Mordor. In the books, while the character
almost certainly dies when Sauron is defeated,
he doesn't get any definitive last words.
In the film, though, he's beheaded by
Aragorn after foolishly taunting the
long-lost king of Gondor. His last words
before he's unceremoniously executed are,
"And who is this? Isildur's heir? It takes more
to make a king than a broken elvish blade."
Gollum's last words come during
his moment of greatest triumph,
right before he meets his demise. The
single-minded creature inadvertently saves the day
by attacking Frodo Baggins in Mount Doom when he
chooses to claim the Ring rather than destroy it.
Biting off Frodo's ring finger, Gollum
finally reclaims his most prized possession,
but then slips off the edge of the
cliff and falls to a fiery death.
In the film The Return of the
King, his final words are a
victorious chant before Frodo tackles
him and they both tumble off the cliff.
"Yes! Precious, precious, precious, precious!"
In the book, Gollum also gleefully repeats the
word "precious" over and over. But in Tolkien's
version, he then steps backward just a tad too
far and slips to his death, without any help
from Frodo. His final word comes out of the
depths as he wails "precious" one last time.
While Sauron doesn't technically "die," nor have
any recorded last words, his ending is still worth
noting as the main antagonist of the trilogy.
Whether you're talking about his fiery eye falling
from a crumbling tower in the films, or the more
spiritual implication of his defeat in the books,
his epic fall marks the
climax of the entire trilogy.
In the book The Return of the King,
Gandalf explains what will happen to Sauron
after the Ring is destroyed, saying that,
"If [the Ring] is destroyed, then [Sauron]
will fall; and his fall will be so low that
none can foresee his arising ever again. [...]
He will lose the best part of the strength that
was native to him in his beginning, and all that
was made or begun with that power will crumble,
and he will be maimed forever, becoming a
mere spirit of malice that gnaws itself in
the shadows, but cannot again grow or take shape."
So while Sauron may not be
dead or have formal last words,
there's no doubt that his fall marks
a turning point for Middle Earth.
Grishnákh is an orc captain that shows
up for a brief stint in The Two Towers
when Merry and Pippin are being
dragged across Rohan. In the book,
he's the chief of the soldiers who serve the
Dark Lord. He resists the Uruk-hai captain Uglúk,
who wants to speed the prisoners to Saruman
in Isengard rather than Sauron in Mordor.
In Tolkien's original iteration, Grishnákh tries
to spirit away the Hobbits from Uglúk's soldiers
so he can have the One Ring for himself. In
this process, we hear his last words, which are,
"Untie your legs? I'll untie every string
in your bodies. Do you think I can't search
you to the bones? Search you! I'll
cut you both to quivering shreds.
I don't need the help of your legs to get
you away — and have you all to myself!"
After this, he tries to escape with
both Hobbits, but he's ridden down and
skewered by a Rider of Rohan, bringing
his chapter-long role to a sudden end.
In Peter Jackson's adaptation, the villain's
fate is even worse. He survives the Rohirrim raid
and chases the Hobbits into Fangorn Forest.
Limping and already bloodied from wounds,
he yanks Merry out of a tree and says,
"Let's put a maggot hole in your belly."
Unfortunately for Grishnákh, he doesn't
realize Treebeard is waking up behind him,
and the Ent promptly stomps him out of existence.
Háma is the doorward of Edoras, charged
with guarding Théoden's house. However,
it turns out he isn't great at his job, since he
lets Gandalf into the hall with his staff in hand,
inadvertently enabling the wizard to free
Théoden from Wormtongue's bewitchment.
But apart from his slip-up with the White
Wizard, he's actually a faithful soldier.
In the books, Háma releases Éomer from prison,
arrests Wormtongue, and brings the King of
the Golden Hall his sword. From there, Háma
follows his lord to the Battle of Helm's Deep,
where he tragically dies in the fighting. His
last words come in conversation with a fellow
soldier regarding Théoden's deposed advisor and
the temporarily absent Gandalf. When the fellow
says that Gandalf's eccentric behavior could
be explained by Wormtongue, Háma's response is,
"True enough, but for myself, I will
wait until I see Gandalf again."
In the movie version, Háma doesn't
make it as far as the battle. The
Captain of the King's Guard is
killed on the way to Helm's Deep.
His last words come when he's busy
scouting ahead of the Rohirrim column.
"What is it? Háma?"
"I'm not sure."
A few seconds later, he's
knocked over by a Warg-riding orc
whose mount eats the loyal warrior face first.
Madril is a character that was purely invented
for the Peter Jackson film adaptations.
In The Two Towers, the Gondorian officer
witnesses the events in Ithilien, where
Faramir's forces ambush the Haradrim and then
take Frodo, Sam, and eventually Gollum prisoner.
After that, Madril heads back with the troop
of rangers when they return to Osgiliath.
In The Return of the King, he can be seen helping
Faramir prepare the hopeless defense of the same
ruined city. When the invading forces, led by
the disfigured Gothmog, swarm across the river,
they overrun the garrison with little effort.
Amongst the Gondorian casualties is Madril,
whose last onscreen words are as a faithful
second in command. After saving his captain
from his Orc pursuers, he advises his lord,
"We can't hold them. The city is lost."
Not long afterward, Madril is knocked down
by his enemies and receives a cold-blooded
spear to the heart from Gothmog as he
lays helplessly in his enemy's path.
While not technically dead, Frodo Baggins
absolutely deserves to be on a list of last
words from the heroes of Middle-earth.
At the end of The Return of the King,
the Ring-bearer sails away into blissful
retirement in the Undying Lands. But the truth
is that he does so because he's so spiritually
devastated by the ordeal of carrying the Ring
that he basically can't endure
life in Middle-earth anymore.
As Frodo prepares to leave, he tells Sam that
although he was successful in saving the Shire,
the peaceful life that he once lived
is no longer available to him. Then,
as he gives Sam the book he's written
about their adventures, he adds,
"The last pages are for you, Sam."
In the book, after explaining why he's realized
he cannot remain in the Shire, Frodo tells his
ever-loyal gardener and best friend that he is
his heir and must stay behind with his family.
Frodo then finishes with an invitation for Sam
to come and see him off at the harbor, saying,
"Come now, ride with me!"
The Lord of the Rings may not be Bilbo
Baggins' story, but the entire adventure
wouldn't have taken place if it weren't for
his epic adventure half a century beforehand.
By the end of The Lord of the Rings,
Bilbo is a very old Hobbit who is
waning quickly without the power of
the One Ring to keep him from aging.
The Hobbit hero leaves his comfy retirement pad
in Rivendell at the end of The Return of the
King. He's feeling very old at this point, but
he rallies his strength to head overseas to the
immortal Blessed Realm — an honor he's earned
due to his legacy as one of the Ring-bearers.
In the Return of the King book, Bilbo's last line
comes when he meets Frodo and Sam on their way to
the Grey Havens. Upon seeing them, Bilbo proudly
declares to Frodo that, thanks to the help of
the One Ring, he has finally become the oldest
Hobbit of all time, surpassing even the lifespan
of the Old Took. His last line immediately
follows this statement as he tells his cousin,
"And now, I think I am quite ready to
go on another journey. Are you coming?"
In the movie adaptation, the line doesn't
come until they actually reach the harbor,
at which point the elderly Bilbo proclaims,
"I think I'm quite ready for another adventure."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Middle Earth
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.